[Music]
hello and welcome to episode number 66
of the weekly Google cloud platform
podcast I am francisca boy and I'm here
with my colleague mark modèle hey Mark
how are you doing I'm good thanks
Francis I realized we still have the
same insurer where we say roots the
weekly Google cloud platform progress
but it is alien daily with the daily
weekly in the daily Google cloud
platform focused indeed indeed but soon
move back to weekly thank God oh yes
there's the third episode in a row we've
released one on the one of Google Cloud
next then they too this is on day three
but we're gonna be covering everything
that happened during date true who which
was a lot which was a lot yeah pretty
intense day we're about to finish we're
here on the ground floor so if you
listen to this episode come say hi later
yeah and we have an interview with a
bunch we have actually a bunch of
interviews with some of Google partners
yeah so we're going to talk to a variety
partners that we've literally plucked
from the show floor to come to talk to
us about what they provide on top of our
services but also like how they use our
services and like what they're excited
about for here at next most of them came
to be interviewed voluntarily yes some
of them some of them but yeah we're
gonna have a bunch of them but before
that I thought that it was there's been
so many announcements that I think we
should mention out like just our
favorite my favorites yeah so I got
first why not so if you remember back in
a previous episode we had a question of
the week where we actually went through
and said all the things that you could
use for free yep on Google cloud
platform so now there's actually first
of all a dedicated page you can go to
cloud.google.com / free nice and it
lists out all the free tears that we
have that are available some of them are
new some of them are old oh yeah so that
you can see what it is you're able to
use for free on the platform now that's
not the only thing which is cool so
before if you give them in for free
trial it was 300 rollers or 60 days
right off you normally hit the 60 days
well before you hit the terms oh yeah
unless you're doing like really cool
stuff i knows one which is fine too but
now in three hundred dollars or 12
months nice that is very good yeah so
you have a whole year to basically use
google cloud platform with that 300
roses if you're doing like smaller stuff
or dev stuff right
a whole bunch of time there to get
started and have a play that's pretty
amazing what about you what's your
favorite thing I'm gonna say that my
favorite thing also not necessary for me
because I've never used posterous but
for so many people that have asked this
question before oh is that we do now
support postgresql on managed as a
manage database on cloud sequel cool
which is amazing I mean it is simple
yeah but basically now you can create a
managed instance so you get all the cool
things about being managed he will not
go down we manage updates we manage
security we manage patches we manage all
the things so you just need to take care
about your data really so that is
amazing very excited about lots of
people have been asked over here for
quite a while so we finally have it and
very happy with that cool so why don't
we go off and chat with our friends at
tableau and get started yeah let's go
with that joining us on the moscone
floor we are joined today by monton
Sleiman from tableau martin how are you
doing great thanks are you guys doing
excellent before we talk about what like
tableau and partners and all that good
stuff tell us a little bit about who you
are what do you do at a blow sure my
name is Martin and I'm a tableau product
manager for tableau I worry about
connectivity so I'm really interested in
all different types of data sources
especially Google ones close so the only
thing I know is that one of the data
sources is bigquery and that Felipe
Hoffa one hour Tim it that's really cool
stuff with it but could you tell us a
little bit more what can you do with
tableau given a like a big query data
source for it oh sure absolutely yeah we
have we do a lot with Google bigquery
we've been integrated with it for a long
time it allows you to really see under
and understand your data so you can do
all sorts stuff we have a demo we're
going to show this week that using some
of that public New York taxi data which
i have people about like what time or
people getting picked up the most where
they being picked up what how many of
these disputes are happening and where
those disputes occurring or when it was
those disputes occurring so it's really
kind of cool to be loved seeing this
huge data set actually be able to
understand and get some insights into it
just by looking at some great
visualizations that we can do nice and
you have a booth here today
is there that demo is gonna be there are
you actually having a session are you
speaking at the conference here yeah
great question we both have a booth and
at that booth you can actually see the
NYC taxi devil should be great lots
night on also on a Thursday vadie one of
my comrades will be actually giving a
presentation with Tim swass from google
itself yeah it's called visualizing big
data on google cloud so will be part of
that which is great so if you're not
physically here check out that recording
that's really good what are you are you
demoing like big korean templo or
tableau and other things what are you
actually showing that we will be showing
just the general integration but we
focused on Google bigquery nice and
other than that session why do the
sessions are you excited about I'm
actually excited about some of the other
sort of big data sessions and also sort
of how to actually I immersing one about
migrating data into Google bigquery I
was really excited about and i'm also
kinda interested about the machine
learning stuff because i know you guys
have been doing a lot investing a lot
into machine learning and we'd love to
see how that's going to work out curious
about it today we had they won keynote
and there was at VN a lot of machine
learning going on could you have a
comment on it that you watched the
keynote yeah i saw like you know it was
really cool the best part of that i
thought was when she showed the ability
for them to understand video now and so
she put in a search term basically
saying beaches right and so it search
through all of the video and i found you
just the clips of beaches which i
thought was for me so that was sarah and
she's one of our teammates and she's
amazing yeah that was great that was a
great day my yep awesome well Martin
thanks so much for coming and joining us
and do a little interview with us and I
hope you have a really great club next
hey thanks very much it's been great
thanks again Martin for joining us from
tableau super interesting conversation
visualizations are always hugely hugely
important way to go data yeah big data
with our visualizations is not really
big data you want to be able to extract
things and show them to people so they
can understand advising it so yeah
tableau perfect tool for that so next up
we have ed from fastly talking about
really cool stuff around CD ends and
like basically trying to get information
to people as fast as possible very
fastly very fastly nice I like it so
next in club next we have at bender from
fastly Hyatt how are you doing I'm doing
great how are you doing
so very good very excited about
everything that is going on and also I
want to learn more about fat lead but
why don't you tell us first about what
do you do it fast and then we'll talk
about what fast it does sounds great so
I'm on our strategic partnerships team
we work with a lot of cloud companies as
well as infrastructure as a service
ecosystem members we work globally we've
got customers all over the world and
it's kind of our job to make sure that
we're doing the right things with the
major origin cloud providers in the
world nice cool so you work for fastly
what is fast leader fastly is an edge
network it does edge delivery edge
defense edge data streaming edge compute
traditionally these were known as CD
ends and the space has evolved quite a
bit to be handling a lot of more
interesting workloads at the edge so you
know we run the gamut of streaming media
protecting sites and delivering dynamic
assets cool and I know that fastly and
Google cloud platform are pre related
could use a little bit more about that
relationship sure we've been a part of
the Google next conference series for
three years since the first one and
we've taken that globally from Tokyo
Paris New York and so on our
relationship with Google originated when
we had a large customer leaving a legacy
CDN who needed a place to store their
assets we quickly identified google as
being the preferred partner for storage
solution and since then it's evolved
into handling a number of integrations
both from a network standpoint of
product standpoint and go to market and
i think you're talking about it
specifically those topics during one of
the sessions tomorrow right that's right
our CEO is speaking tomorrow morning as
part of the storage track track it's at
11 20 m a.m. in room 2010 his name's
Arthur Bergman and it's alongside the
wonderful product manager career tropin
nice cool so yeah if you're not here
obviously you can get the recording but
while you're here are you excited about
any announced
that have come today or maybe any
sessions that are coming up in the next
few days I gotta say I'm most excited at
least at first glance by the sheer
volume of this next there's so many
people here yeah and it's been amazing
to kind of ride alongside google for
this whole past few years as cloud has
become a larger and larger part of the
business we're definitely growing that's
for sure yeah it's Moscone right we're
not messing around it's good great well
thanks so much ed for taking the time to
talk with to us and have a great next
thank you so much take care guys thanks
so yeah thanks ed force it's an
interesting conversation a lots of cool
stuff going on at fastly and next up we
have Jonathan Lieberman from I topia and
I gotta say that when we started talking
to him I had no idea what they did and
it is a very cool thing it is a very
cool thing yeah so they basically manage
workspaces must be like windows
workspaces so you can imagine like at
the office space mm-hmm so you can
imagine all of those uh workspaces being
migrated to the cloud yeah and the
running Google clapham so let's talk to
Jonathan Lieberman so we're joined today
by Jonathan Lieberman from I topia a
technology partner with Google cloud
platform before we get into I topia and
what it's all about Jonathan why don't
you tell us a little bit about what you
do at I topia right thank you so thank
you for having me and the CEO and
co-founder of I topia and we're really
excited to be here at Google next 17
where we just rolled out and announced
our partnership with with Google and
we're really excited to be here so yeah
why don't you tell us a little about
what a tebya does what's the what's the
whole thing with a topia so we built we
built a technology stack for IT service
providers to make it super easy for them
to move windows work spaces into the
Google cloud ok so I'm a company maybe I
have like a million desktops or
something like that right and then I
want to like consolidate my resources
somehow is that kind of the deal right
so what that's a great use case and
essentially what happens is that you're
facing end of life on your server
infrastructure you're evaluating your
options are you going to buy you know
and build something new or are you going
to move into
cloud and and we were here to help you
move into the Google cloud and
essentially lift and shift everything
that you have into the Google cloud
including your servers your desktops
applications data everything that you
have right now running your company cool
so when you're saying that you're moving
the desktops and the workshop the
workspaces does that mean that once
you're an employee of a company using I
topia whenever you log in you're
actually using some remote desktop that
is running on our cloud or how does that
exactly work that's exactly how it
happened so once we've migrated the user
into the cloud they'll access their
desktop when they from any device
anywhere anytime through an icon it
might be a remote desktop services could
be something else and it's it's a remote
user experience the user clicks on the
icon and they're now on their desktop
running their software and processing
and storage to go through the Google
cloud so okay I'll ask the question why
did you choose Google's out for us that
came down to three choices first of all
we we looked at everything in the market
and at the end of the day Google stood
tallest when it came to performance
price and your technology you know from
a performance standpoint we recognize
and and understand that you used that
your google cloud is the same thing that
runs g sweet that runs your search that
runs your Maps everything the lowest
latency in the market and for our
service you need a low latency and so
having data centers throughout the world
is a very key differentiator that we
looked at from a price point of view you
build down to the minute compared with
the others that bill on an hourly basis
and then from a technology point of view
everything that you're doing from
machine learning to AI to everything
else was also very important to us as we
want to deliver the most innovative
services to our to our customers cool so
what does it entail to be partnered with
Google Cloud
so we went through a very extreme
vetting process and uh and you all
looked at our technology we we connected
with the team that handles the types of
use cases and the types of things that
we do we worked with your engineers they
kick the tires and at the end of the day
they came back with with thumbs up and
invited us to be part of your your
program cool so what does it mean now
what are the kind of advantage is that
you get as a partner so we get to join
your ecosystem partners from your g
sweet ecosystem to Chromebooks and
education and in some cases even large
enterprises that are need help and a
technology stack to move their clients
into the cloud and that's why we're so
excited because they can they can
partner with us to do that fantastic all
right so we're here at cloud next though
like what are you excited about what are
you hearing about like their sessions
you're going to you think you're going
to be really cool what's what's awesome
for you a little bit of everything enjoy
the keynotes this morning the Diane
Greene just SAT through the fireside
chat with Vince surf and Max and
Driessen cool and that was super
interesting and then also walking the
the show floor we've been able to
connect with some of your premier
partners we we intend to be to be one of
them next year so I got to got to hear
some anecdotes about how to do that and
and in really just being here able to
network with with people that can use
our technology has been super awesome
well thank you so much for taking your
time out of I'm guessing a very busy
schedule here at next it's been really
great having you come and join us in the
podcast booth and I hope you have a
great next thank you appreciate that so
cool I know you and I don't do a lot
with Windows but huge numbers of people
clearly do so thanks to jonathan for
coming on the podcast and having a quick
chat about I topia finally last but
definitely not least we have James
Williams from Udacity told ya Udacity
google cloud we've talked it about a
bunch of times yeah but still really
interesting especially if you want to
learn more about google cloud and I'm
happy to have James on the podcast for
two reasons one is I i love you the city
they're really really good and second
he's a good friend of mine so let's talk
to James sounds good so I'm very happy
to welcome today to the podcast one of
my dear friends James Williams from
Udacity hello James how are you doing
hello I'm doing good uh you got dear
friend I don't get dear friend and you
just got hey you should be happy with
colleges point so why don't you tell us
a little bit about what you do at
Udacity alright i am a android
curriculum lead at Udacity so I kind of
shape and guide the decisions about what
we should cover and how we should cover
in stuff like that but I've also done
some web courses with Udacity like there
was a web tooling course that I deal
with Paul bakas know if people don't
know what you density is what is Udacity
Udacity is a online education company we
have lots of free and awesome courses
we'd have a credential called a
nanodegree that allows people to take
horses get project reviews mentor
feedback and things like that and we
have lots of free courses with Google so
do you have some courses that you'd like
to highlight especially we related to
cloud there is a cooper Nettie's course
with a two-day to a catalog our
encounter Morgan there you go yeah like
the really dapper dressing do ya see ya
that's probably the most related to
cloud cool so since you're here visiting
cloud necks what is the most exciting
session for you out of the next three
things so do I have to say your session
no you guys go everyone has been saying
princess session okay my session stadium
it's not um so I would say like it's
it's always fun to see you know your
friends present so I'm going to check
out princess session
probably also groovy product we'd give
Lafourche yeah I'm going to check out
his session as well and try and get to
some of the stuff on App Engine and
Google cloud engine great cool all right
well thank you so much for joining us
here at our little podcast a SAT the
floor of muscle our next let's go anyway
yeah um yeah thank you for taking the
time yep have a good plot next no
worries thanks you guys too so thanks
again thanks so much to james williams
from the audacity for taking the time to
talk a little bit about what they're up
to and Udacity there's a lot of things
to check out from Udacity as we said is
that very very good kuber 90 is a course
with our friends Kelsey Hightower and
Carter Morgan yep but on top of that
there's and so many other things to
check out oh my god so many things to
check out yesterday so as we said last
yesterday we had an episode where we
interviewed a bunch of really cool
people one of them Claire she's I think
she calls herself our Tsar of collapse
yeah and as she mentioned all of those
cutlets are online so go check yesterday
yesterday's episode for a link to those
collapse yep and on top of that there's
so many announcements yeah to make sure
hop online a lot of the videos are on
YouTube right now actually yeah by the
time this episode comes out which will
be up some sometime tomorrow morning
every day friday morning yeah probably
our talks already online so go check it
out yeah so absolutely there'll be a
link in the show notes to the YouTube
channel I know they'll least beer at
least around 70 videos that are
available yeah everything from they want
it is there a foreshore from they true
most of it will be by then so go check
it out there's a lot of things to learn
and if you're around come say hi come
say hi yeah if you're here come say hi
with stickers we have t-shirts love
talking to everyone who's involved in
the podcast so that's it right check out
the podcast we got daily episodes this
blog post on the Google Cloud blog
there's youtube videos the Udacity
courses this code labs usually cannot be
bored yeah there's so much stuff to do
so for all of those that are here come
say hi for all of those that are far
away from San Francisco
go check all of those resources out
bunch of links in the show notes and no
matter where you are talk to y'all
tomorrow see you tomorrow
you